tu pars mentir on arrive aux cinq
dernières minutes et avec notre amitié
et cette invitée c'est comme on dit
bryce de nice on dit ce qu'on veut on
dit ce qu'on veut on dit parisot nice a
dit à ce genre du jardin les assauts
loulou le cumulard mais c'est tout ça ça
fait beaucoup
alors j'ai plein de question de
l'oreillette on me disait mais comme on
dit ça farte c'est ça on dit ça farte
voilà c'est ça on dit sa femme c'est
bien ça c'est le ça farte oui je sais
venu ça aurait pu être ça glisse ça
vient du dictionnaire voilà j'ai trouvé
ça farte me soutient ce serait pas mal à
voir qu'il y en avoir aussi son bonjour
qu'il est son bonjour à lui donc voilà
ça y est vous l'avez cherché voulait
travailler loin quand on écrit un sketch
on cherche des mots comme ça on y tient
farter farter ça fort bien ça tape ça me
plaît je prends d'accord mais voilà ça
j'ai répondu la question qu'on pose est
est-ce que vous avez vous rendez compte
que vous êtes en train de devenir comme
on dit dans la presse un véritable
phénomène de société ou l'agrément lui
non je dirais un modèle un exemple
obliger à être être très prétentieux non
je peux pas dire ça et je suis ravi de
ce qui se passe évidemment mais
maintenant ce phénomène c'est le blond
qui sort tout cas qui marchent pas c'est
le surfeur qui marche moi encore je suis
protégé par sa non ça le blond le
surfeur et son maillot étriqué son grand
shirt on va le voir tout de suite dans
ce petit extrait de brice de nice on
regarde le plateau de mercy pour qui
c'est pour toi
c'est pour quatre personnes
elle a pas bougé la mer la fin je
n'étais pas là elle va bouger la mère
divine c'est ce qu'on va faire
tu regarde ma mère si elle du sou elle
tu m'appelles hockey
sans la liberté allez d'accord m'appelle
bright et ex ces prêts gratuits
c'est bon et comment on dit parce qu'il
y avait le hockey lah de des visiteurs
vous c'est le cas c'est cassé oui c'est
ça peut prendre tout en haut il faut le
finir c'est ça sa part dit dans les
précédents les récrés ce moyen des
jeunes qui faisaient cassé je sais pas
pourquoi maintenant j'ai compris en
voyant le film que cet effet il y avait
travolta aussi mais maintenant il ya
effectivement il y avait ça aussi c'est
et travailler ça a été travaillée au
départ le cas c'était plus timide 1 et
puis c'est vrai je les jeux léa mort
c'est comme ça et je me suis c'est plus
absurde enfin voila je voulais rester
sur le cac c'est alors on vous codé nous
on vous a pas découvert là dedans vous à
découvrir d'abord sur france 2 avec elle
un gars une fille est en fait pendant
que vous faisiez un gars une fille brice
de nice de niles votre personnage
continuer de vivre ce que vous l'aviez
créé avant absolument moi j'ai raccroché
avec brice de nice je faisais des petits
modules avec ce personnage en 99 avec
mes amis les nous c nous et puis
effectivement j'avais lâché donc la
perruque je me suis dit jean terre le
personnage je passe à autre chose et
c'est vrai qu'il a continué à vivre
grâce à notamment alexandre pietra et
rémy lanvin qui ont créé un site sur
brice et voilà c'est grâce à eux aussi
pendant cinq jours à terme elle devrait
absolument vous fans on continue à
s'échanger des berrichons par résultats
inégaux m'appeler brice qu'on m'appelle
brice encore dans la rue c'était très
très étonnant mais effectivement c'est à
la force du net a priori moi je suis ni
surfer dans la vie ni surfer sur le net
donc je me rendais pas vraiment compte
bon d'où ils venaient d'ailleurs ce
surfeur il vient il vient y vient de ma
tête
il vient d'engager rencontrer d un bri
en terminale qui était comme ça un
personnage créé par an de recul qui est
assez intéressant qui se moquer de tout
le monde et puis je les fais connecter
avec des surfeurs de la côte atlantique
je me suis dit ça pourrait faire un
personnage intéressant pour le prochain
café théâtre voilà donc c'est un mélange
de plein de personnes mais est-ce que
cet humour vous vous reconnaissez dans
les jackass dans l'est
michaël youn dont ces gens là ou non a
priori non j'ai juste j'ai juste suis
mon instinct je me suis dit il faut que
je fasse je m'amuse coup je retrouve la
même fraîcheur j'avais sur scène ou à la
télé je me suis dit il faut vraiment que
m'amuser à 21 ans vie d'un personnage de
composition un personnage entier absurde
il faut les mots est un peu con
aujourd'hui un humain peut être
quelqu'un je n'ai pas eu l'écho où il
est plutôt décalé différent je dirais
pas qu'on mais s'il vous plaît ne
perçoivent aucun nom mais c'est le repas
dans l'un il est pas con il est juste
décalé c'est un personnage qui est
vraiment décalé qui est en quête en
circuit fermé dans sa bulle jaune et
le monde autour ne l'est pas lui en tout
cas les voilà il n'aspire qu'une façon
c'est ça casse la baraque
vous avez dépassé les 1 million de
millions d'entre elles et veulent en a
deux a pas d'accord et puis il y aura un
paris nice tous deux peut-être à la
neige wilfred là il fera de la loge est
fort et il fera aussi beaucoup partira
sûrement
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'être venu
voilà on arrive à la fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo c'est nathalie